it's hard changing your life
it was hard when just over three years
ago
in the penobscot building in detroit
michigan
where i was operating my business and i
fell on some hard times
and i was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said excuse me mr brown can
we see you for a moment
and i said yes and i walked up to the
counter and he gave me an envelope
and he said would you mind reading it
here and i opened the envelope
and the envelope was from management
that says this
is an office tower it's not a hotel
please do not sleep in your office
and i said excuse me sir i said i just
worked long hours
in creating my business i'm an
entrepreneur
and right now things are bad for me but
they're not going to be
this way always
and i just asked for the opportunity to
continue to operate
like i'm doing i'm not trying to make
this my home
and it was hard coming through the lobby
and sometimes they would laugh there's a
guy talking about becoming successful
and look at him he's bathing in the
bathroom upstairs
on the 21st floor he sleeps on the floor
him and two other dreamers up there look
at them
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people
and i was facing financial difficulties
in my own life
i was behind on my bills and my dreams
and i'm saying to them
you can live your dream it was hard
ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing
that i could do it there were times that
i doubted myself
i said god why why is this happening to
me
i'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother i'm not trying to
steal a rock from anybody
how did this have to happen to me
it was very hard and here's what i want
to say to you
for those of you that have experienced
some hardships
don't give up on your dream no one could
have convinced me by holding on
by continuing to push forward by
continuing to run toward my dream
that one day i would have my own
talk show it's a long shot ladies and
gentlemen from liberty city an abandoned
building on a floor
never knowing my mother or father it's a
long shot
being here with you today in this dome
in atlanta it's a long shot no college
training labeled educable mentally
[ __ ]
but i kept running toward my dreams
don't stop
don't stop
[Applause]
don't stop running towards your dream
it's very important as you hold on to
that dream there are moments when you're
going to doubt yourself
their rough times are going to come but
they have not come to stay
they have come to pass it's very
important for you to know that
don't say i'm having a bad day say i'm
having a character building day
[Applause]
it's very important for you to believe
that you are the one to make this happen
i remember
this high school teacher mr leroy
washington
at the end of school one june it was
just a few days before we were supposed
to
leave and i just got my report card
and it indicated that i'd failed history
and i'd fail english
and i would have to go to summer school
and i was feeling within myself
that i was a failure that i i'm slower
than most people
and getting paperwork and and i was
feeling down on myself
and and very negative and mr washington
was giving a speech to the graduating
seniors and i was in 11th grade
and even though i wasn't supposed to be
in there i went in there because
the speech he was giving that speech
was for me and as he talked my heart
began
to beat fast tears began to run by my
eyes and i was in the back just
listening to him
because he said and he was a very
dramatic man
i still talked to him to this day he
said as graduating seniors of booker t
washington high school
i want you to know that you're blessed
and highly favored
and that as you go toward the future
begin to know that you have greatness
within you
and if just one of you here begin to
envision yourselves as being blessed and
highly favored
to reach your goals if just one of you
capture the essence of what that means
that you have greatness within you
and responsibility to manifest that
greatness
that you can make your parents proud you
can make your school proud
you can touch millions of people's lives
and the world will never be the same
again
because you came this way and the
students gave him a rousing
standing ovation and as he left the
auditorium i ran down the steps and i
caught him in the parking lot
i said mr washington he said yes i said
do you remember me
sir he said no i said um
my name is leslie brown my mother she
works in the cafeteria here i'm one of
the twins
leslie wesley i said mr washington but
you know you know i got these big dreams
you know i like talking to people i love
people
i said i want to work with people and i
got this dream of buying my mama home
could could i do that mr washington he
said it's possible mr brown
and as he walked away i called him again
i said mr washington
he said what do you want now
i said um
i'm the one sir i said
i'm the one you you remember me sir i'm
this maybe brown's boy
i'm the word
i'm the one
[Applause]
and you must feel that
that that's why you're here because you
are the one
and i remember when pbs first played one
of my specials called you deserve
one sunday afternoon in miami florida i
had some friends call him
to tell him to tune in and he watched
the program he called me in detroit and
i answered the phone i said hello he
said may i speak to les brown please
i said who's calling he said you know
who this is
i said oh mr washington it's you he said
you were the one weren't you i said yes
sir
he said and you were so crazy i said i
know but i'm rich now
ladies and gentlemen it's not going to
be easy
it was hard laying on the floor of the
penobscot building
looking out of the window daydreaming
saying les can you do this
can you make this happen i used to
listen to
tapes day in and day out about see you
at the top my
my great friend zig and and dennis
waitland different other motivational
speakers and dr norman vincent peale
and dex is saying don't let nobody steal
your dream
i used to ask myself can i do this
and something said within me you're the
one
you're the one and let me tell you
something ladies and gentlemen
while you're here and before you go back
home to your respective cities
and communities write down at least five
reasons
on why you deserve your dream and why
you won't give up
what's going to make you unstoppable why
you must be unreasonable because logical
practical thinking says
you can't do it today but if you want to
produce
unreasonable results in your life like
living your dreaming taking charge of
your destiny you've got to be
an unreasonable person you've got to be
an uncommon person
so write down the reasons of why you're
here
my first major goal was to buy my mother
a home
and let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen what what will reasons do less
nietzsche said if you know the wife for
doing you can endure almost
anyhow what do you mean by that if you
know why you're doing something
when the hard times come and they're
going to come when the disappointments
and the rejections come and they're
going to come by the truckloads
your reasons will be your rod and staff
to comfort you
to pick you up once again i got a saying
on one of my tapes if life
knocks you down try and land on your
back because if you can look up
you can get up let your reasons get you
back up
i feel like most people in their lives
are
being allowed to live small you're
allowed to live a small life everyone
around you would like you to live small
just do this you're good at that man
take it easy chill when's enough enough
like come on brother you know where we
where we all these messages you get is
basically saying hey man
live small yeah life's not a big deal
live small enjoy it chill smoke a little
weed do whatever you want
right like it's just this get by thing
in life and there's got to be some
people going no
no you're supposed to do something great
with your life you were put here for a
purpose
your way the way you were born the way
you were raised
your background your experiences your
giftedness
all prepared you in your way for right
now
and you're supposed to do something
great with your life you weren't born
here to be average and ordinary
and there's all this messaging that
you're average and ordinary and you're
averaging
because you belong there and it's
probably someone else's fault you're
averaging ordinary to it i'm like no
it's your life you're in control it's no
one else's fault and you're supposed to
do something
magnificent that's the consciousness
aspect the last
thousand years on earth doing something
great has been reserved to this one
little group of people
one percent of the population they're
supposed to do something great
they're supposed to live their dreams
we're supposed to watch them cheer for
them
wear their jersey watch their award show
comment on their posts clean their
houses
right feed them in their restaurants no
the fact of the matter is
you can do those things you can change
your life and i'm sick and tired of this
hero worship you live small cheer for
everybody else who lives big
no if you're a school teacher be the
best damn school teacher change the
world by those little lives you're
affecting
if you're on social media change the
world play big
you will never do it wrong if your
decision is to do the bigger thing than
the smaller thing
that's what i would tell you stop
playing small stop thinking small and
don't let anybody tell you you should be
small
you get your ass kicked along the way
things go sideways
things go wrong people let you down
partners don't work
out money falls out all these things
happen
but i want you to reframe it in your
mind success auditor
success tax auditor is looking looking
and going
okay let's put another obstacle in front
of wendy's way
let's see if she can get through that oh
she saw the obstacle turn around went
back
i don't think she's going to be the one
that reaches her full potential but she
could just live life like everybody else
and she'll be okay
let's see about liberio let's see what's
up liberia let's throw some crap in
front of him
let's throw some fears in front of him
let's throw a massive obstacle
wow he fought it he was a little sad it
was a little tough a little stressful
couple sleepless nights
but he's still going okay check that box
let's wait about three months and throw
some more in his way
and that's what i believe success tax is
i think we have to go through the trials
and tribulations we have to build the
grit we have to build the wisdom
or else we don't deserve it i teach my
daughter she's
killing it in softball i said you win
when no one else is watching you have to
pay your success tax
by practicing all the time when no one's
cheering no one's excited no one's doing
it over the summer she's down here in my
office pitching
because she's paying her success tax but
guess what in the fall when she plays
she's going to kill it
when she comes out and all her friends
can be like oh my god everybody's
admiring you you got the game ball i
wish i could do that you wish you could
do it
pay success tax if you're not willing to
pay get out of the freaking game
don't think it says listen everybody
wants to be on stage
in front of 50 000 people jamming and
singing with everybody going crazy in
the crowd singing their name
but you know what everybody's not
willing to do is play in their room
until their fingers bleed to pack up an
old
van and drive around to gig to get when
two people show up
most people aren't willing to do that
everybody looks at the beatles on how
amazing they were right
you know the beatles played like 10 000
different uh over over the years they
played almost every night like six
nights a week sometimes two gigs a night
for years and years and years never
being noticed sometimes one person in
the audience
they paid their success tax and then all
of a sudden they were an overnight
sensation
they weren't an overnight sensation so
think of it that way frame it
as success tax is part of the journey
and if you could say i'm not saying you
need to like the crap
i'm not saying you have to like the
journey i'm not saying you have to like
when somebody screws you over the deal
goes sideways
but what if you go wow if i get through
this
i get another checkbox from the success
tax
auditor you start looking at life that
way things change
and you realize you're here because
you're learning those skills to get
through them easier and quicker
most of the world most of the world sees
a wall
and they turn around and go back they're
not deserving of the success
you are the type that will pound through
it get under it get around it
climb over it or blow it up with
dynamite and that's who wins the game
so with that said let's take it a step
further
because i can talk about this until i'm
blue and like
i could talk about this every moment of
every day when it comes to my business
because i've
crushed it in my business those fears
that i had of being a broke kid
i didn't i didn't have the right
education i didn't go to college i
didn't have money i didn't come from the
right town
my parents both worked to make you know
probably 35 grand combined separately
and we always stressed about money and i
lived in a bathroom with my dad i lived
in a trailer park with my mom until we
got evicted
i mean crazy stuff right in business i
overcame all those fears i failed
miserably winston churchill said the
definition of success is going from
failure to failure without losing your
enthusiasm well i
i did that before i ever read that quote
and i kept going i paid my success tax
i failed miserably and i made it and in
business i can make those decisions i
can i can fail miserably i can lose
millions of dollars on a deal and i
could be over in a day
i could i could have faith in someone
i'm working with and they let me down
and it hurts and i'm over in a day
i can rebound fast learn from it and go
i have trained my body i've trained my
my my insides i've trained my physiology
i've trained my
words i've trained my subconscious that
we are freaking
unstoppable nothing as a combined body
and unit nothing can stop us
i believe that fear gets way too much
airplay you know i think
so many people say well people don't
take action because they have too much
fear
or fear is holding people back and i
think this is so common in our language
it's almost
the point where it's almost comedic it's
ridiculous it's
like what are they fearful of what are
they so scared of you know we live in
the modern world right now where there's
not all these impulsive fears that are
are driven by a physical reality to be
safe you know we're not being
chased by animals that are trying to
kill us often right
so most of the fears that we actually
have are just
negative contemplative thoughts that
we're rerunning
too often and we're associating so much
pain to that now becomes convenient oh
it's fear
as if some fear is some big unknowable
scary awful thing well mostly it's not
most fear is just bad management of our
own mental faculties
it's not an impulsive physical thing
generating in our brain
telling us to you know fight fight or
flee and everyone wants to use that
excuse you know we still have
all these you know biological
psychologists or people running around
saying well
it's just an impulsive thing that people
can't understand or
or or be conscious of right it's the
unconscious fears it's just
wiping us out it's like get over it
neuroscience has shown like we have much
more
powerful capabilities than most of us
think that we do and the reality is
most fear once you understand what it
actually
is and it usually is a contemplative
process
and once they understand what it is then
it's like oh we can overcome it
because what is it then i mean what is
fear what are we so scared of
what's going to hurt us what is this
thing that we fear is going to bring so
much pain in our lives
ever thought about it what is it what is
the thing that we're so
scared that's going to bring in all this
pain to our lives
i remember figuring this out for myself
and
when i did i wasn't so scared anymore
because sometimes you know the things
once you understand them more they're
not so terrifying
once something becomes knowable you can
develop competency around it once you
can develop competency around it
then you can develop confidence around
it there's this old thing in psychology
we call the competence
confidence loop the more you understand
something the more confidence you have
in that area
same thing with anything that does
happen to impulsively generate some fear
in yourself
well now once you understand what it is
you can deal with it better
because what we're all fearing is
basically three types of pain
three areas that we might experience
pain in our lives and once we understand
that
we can reorient our la our mindset
around those things
and no longer be frustrated or stopped
by fear
the first thing that we fear pain in in
our lives
is what i call lost pain loss pain is
well if i change my life or i do this
new thing
i'll experience loss and because i
experience loss i don't want to do it so
i'm scared to try it because i might
lose something
that i like i care for i adore i might
if i go and make that big change in my
life
i might lose my job i might lose my
relationship with my spouse i
might lose my connection with my kids i
might lose a passion i might lose a
benefit
right i remember when i wanted to go and
start my own business
everyone was generating all this fear in
you by saying well be careful you know
this is very dangerous brendan you don't
you don't want to quit your job and
lose all that security you have you're
gonna i mean what about your 401 k
brendan you're going to lose your 401k i
mean all these things we think we're
going to fear
and the reality was part of that was
true as i
thought more about the situation i was
concerned
i was fearful that i would lose the
security i had that the job provided
i would lose that steady paycheck we all
want i would lose that predictability of
my career path i would lose that nice
process of having managers around to
kind of coach and consult me into higher
levels of performance i would
lose the peer set i love my co-workers
i lose some of the work that i loved i
would lose that great
lunch and cafeteria you know it's like
you think of all these things you're
gonna lose so you don't make the
decision to quit
same thing like people are going to try
and uh you know
quit uh you know smoking or they're
going to
try and start a diet they're fearful
that they're going to lose that
that smoking break that gives them that
peace and that comfort and that
that sense of calmness from breathing in
deep even though they're bringing
in death you know they they're fearful
oh well if i change my diet i'm going to
lose those foods that i love
so much so i'm not going to change and
that's what people do
they're fearing loss so part of
reorienting our lives
is start focusing on the things that
instead of what we're gonna lose
of what we're gonna gain yeah i might
lose my security for the short term
but over the long term i might have more
freedom i might gain freedom
i i might lose that coaching and that
that
that person who's gonna develop me in
terms of that organizational structure
but over here i'm going to gain greater
challenges
i'm going to grow faster because i'm
going to be doing things faster on my
own
oh you know i'm going to lose that 401k
yeah but i'm going to make a million
dollars over here
you know focusing on those gains see
what happens
in the in the fearful mind it starts
asking this question
what if and it follows that phrase with
a negative statement
what if this terrible thing happens what
if this terrible thing happens
what if this terrible thing happens and
we generate and we stew within our gut
these acids and these fears that
literally trick our mind
into thinking we can't change but once
you understand lost pain is something
you're dealing with
start focusing more on the things that
you will gain
and you're getting over a hurdle we're
changing our brain and body to live in
that future present reality
so that so that you feel connected to a
future instead of the past and when
you're connected to the past
you're looking for it and if you're
looking for it you're separate from it
if you're
being it then then there's there's
there's a
complete change in energy and nobody
changes
until they change their energy and when
you change your energy you change your
life
after 8 500 brain scans i can tell you
that you and i
are at our absolute best when we get
beyond ourselves that is the
elegant moment where we're free enough
to create without any encumbrances
the majority of our thoughts and
feelings
are connected to our sexuality to our
victimization our guilt our suffering
our shame our unworthiness our
self-doubt
or our importance our control
our fear our anger our frustration our
hatred or judgment those
are those are the first three hormonal
centers in the body and
and those first three centers have
everything to do with survival
and those centers are energy consumers
orgasm digestion stress
is a lot of energy that we're drawing
from our very
vital life force yes a resource of light
and information
and we're turning it into chemistry and
we're literally robbing the body's
energy right so
so then living like that for the short
term is okay because the body can move
back to homeostasis it can restore
itself but
when we're over doing that consistently
then there's no energy for growth and
repair there's
because you're living constantly in
survival so again you can eat all the
right food you can do all the right
things but if you're living in anxiety
and fear
and you're viewing your world from the
worst case scenario that could possibly
happen because that's what you do in
survival
there's no energy for growth and repair
there's no energy for healing so
the majority of our thoughts are
signaling
certain circuits in the brain that
signal another part of the brain
limbic brain to make what's called a
neuropeptide neuropeptides are chemical
messengers that signal hormonal centers
so now you're taking thought and you're
storing it as
energy in these energy centers and and
if you're living in survival why would
you open your heart
i mean it's just not a time to open your
heart i mean if you're getting chased by
t-rex
it's not a time to meditate it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to connect
it's not a time to communicate
it's not a time to sit down and go
within it's not a time to be vulnerable
it's time to run fight or hide so i
think survival has been very adaptive
yeah like because if you're being
chased by t-rex you don't run up to
t-rex and say
oh cute little dinosaur let me pet you
that's not adaptive
the fear is adaptive you run from the
unknown you run from challenges right
yes
so if you're living in survival there's
better chances of surviving
if you run from the unknown and by the
way
when you're living in survival at the
infinite potentials in the quantum field
you'll select the worst case scenario in
your mind
and you'll begin to emotionally prepare
yourself for the worst case scenario
because
you have better chances of surviving
there you go if you prepare for the
worst right
so people spend their whole life yes
thinking about the worst thing and
emotionally embracing it while you take
a thought an emotion
or an image and an emotion you're
branding or
conditioning your body into what anxiety
into fear so then you keep doing that
over and over again and over and over
again your the body becomes the mind of
fear and
whether you think you can control it or
not you're gonna have a panic attack
and the panic attack is the body saying
you've conditioned me this way try as
you may with your conscious mind to
control it
right you programmed it subconsciously
then you start worrying about the next
panic attack and it's that very
anticipation
keeps the person on the hamster wheel so
think about it so then
70 percent of the time people in the
world are
living anticipating the next moment
based on their past moment and so
they're laying reality down moment by
moment with the next
known the next predictable moment and so
the hormones of stress
endorse the senses our senses become
heightened when we're under stress and
we become materialists we narrow our
focus on the danger
yes so then you're focusing on matter
you're focusing on the material world
and when you do that you put all your
attention the arousal of the stress
hormones
puts all your attention on your body if
you're being chased by t-rex you better
be paying attention to your body
when people start reaching this moment
my goodness
they're overcoming themselves and now
they're at that perfect
place to create and my definition of
creation is when i forget about myself
that's when you're free so some people
can do it because
they've practiced it other people can't
get beyond the addiction
of a certain emotion that means their
body is still their mind yes
so then if you're sitting in a
meditation and your body's thrown the
kitchen sink at you and saying
ed you're a loser you're never going to
change this is too hard why don't you
quit and you're aware that that's your
body doing that and you say to your body
we're going to sit here and we're going
to sit in this fire and i'm going to
keep applying the formula
and my your brain starts running to all
the emails you have to do and you become
aware of that and return back to the
present moment
you tell the body it's no longer the
mind that you're the mind
now your will is getting greater than
that program and there's a liberation of
energy and every time you do that
that's a victory one of the best
ideas that i've ever heard and this one
has been around for a while
but i think it's really useful right now
it's this
notion it's another belief if you will
just like everything is figureoutable
it's an idea that some people don't
prescribe to but i do
and it's the thought that your life
happens
for you and not to you so sometimes in
my life when things
seem to keep going wrong and when i keep
bumping into walls again and again
or there's just a problem after a
problem after a problem
i'll repeat that to myself as a way to
re-ground
in a notion that i live in
a friendly and growth-oriented universe
and that whatever is occurring right now
there's a possibility for me to see it
through the lens of this is an
opportunity for me to grow
this is an opportunity for me to learn
something to get stronger
to step back and to reshape either how
i'm processing my world how i'm
responding to challenges
or there's something that's valuable and
good there's some learning or growth
opportunity
in this if i am willing to look for it
and find it
now i know that might sound pollyanna
it's like easy for you to say you didn't
lose your business to a fire
but when things go wrong in any of our
lives i feel like
the only thing we can control is how we
contextualize
what actually happened and then how we
choose to respond to that experience
right it's like the life preserver i
hold on to very similar to
the notion that everything is
figureoutable it allows me to pull
myself back
up and look through a clear lens
whenever we've had any kind of
setback or any kind of challenge and we
feel a little bit off-kilter
i always feel like getting back in the
game and getting
moving again and having momentum is how
we find clarity so you probably remember
this
another one of my favorites clarity
comes from engagement not thought
so if even the notion of you going like
hey just for the next two months i'm
going to start baking my brownies again
or i'm going to bake my
i'm going to bake some cakes or maybe i
want to change my pricing structure
maybe i want to be the most expensive
brownies at the farmer's market and
people will be like well what's beth
putting in those brownies because
this must be something special i don't
know but i
do know that by you taking steps towards
what
feels joyous and what feels exciting to
you
your next steps are going to appear they
never come when we're sitting on the
couch thinking about it
they don't come from a place of
stuckness or or
when i say stillness i don't mean
meditation and that's awesome but i just
mean hanging out waiting for the answers
to come to us
i find that the best insights come when
we're moving
physically moving taking a spin class
being on a treadmill taking a run
outside
walking through a park going on a hike
or moving doing the actions that we feel
could lead us in the directions of our
dreams you don't need to know the big
picture right now my friend you just
need to get moving again
and then start paying attention to the
signals who knows who you're going to
meet in the farmer's market
who knows what's going to happen once
you start you know baking those brownies
and an email comes in from nowhere
we can't predict what's going to show up
but i can tell you this
if you follow the joy and you follow the
excitement that's where the magic in
life lies
and i think that's what's going to help
you start regaining that sense of
identity
that you haven't been in touch with
recently and that's what's going to have
your energy start moving again
and the next steps really will reveal
themselves in 12-step programs they say
that you know fear will be doing
push-ups while you sleep and so
that is i think really the truth we wake
up in the morning and we have those
pangs of anxiety or
we have something that triggers some
thought that leads us down a crazy road
of negativity
uh puts us into panic attacks puts us
into really scary places that
are created by our own faith towards
fear
our own belief in fear and really
believing in fear is a choice that you
make
and it's not to say that there aren't
natural fears like we aren't going to
cross the street and run into the middle
of the road or we're not going to put
our hand in fire
and we're recognizing that there is a
part of us that is
wise enough and we have reason and we
have that part of our brain that says no
don't go there
but then there is this whole other
element of fear that's so layered and so
deep and so within our psyche that we've
been carrying with us
for decades that's completely
unnecessary
it's a belief system that is based on
fear from the past that we
reorganize and recreate in the present
and we project onto the future
and so our work is to really detach from
that fear
my favorite lesson from a course in
miracles one of
my most favorite messages is a message
called
laugh at the ego's tiny mad idea and
from a course in miracles perspective
the ego and fear are synonymous so ego
is that fear-based voice that shows up
that keeps us small and keeps us stuck
so laugh at the ego's tiny mad ideas
what an amazing concept right to just
let ourselves
laugh at these mad ideas to look at them
and say
how insane they are and sometimes we're
so deeply
ingrained in the idea that it's hard to
laugh but if we can
begin to see our way out if we can think
our way out
or we can talk our way out we can get to
a place where we can laugh
it's our job to see the insanity and in
that experience of witnessing the
insanity
we learn how to detach from the
real stronghold that the fear has on us
and so our job
is to begin to be that witness that is
ready at all times to laugh at the chaos
laugh at the tiny mad ideas
and so i'd like you all to just take a
moment to write down the fear that's
plaguing you the most today
what is it the fear of being alone the
fear of losing your job the fear of not
having enough money
the fear of not having your body weight
the way you want it to be
what is the fear write it down if you're
as fearless as i may be put it out there
put it on the comments below
put it out there out it outing your ego
is a very very important step
as well so put that out there just list
the fear on the comments below or write
it down in your notebook sacred
and keep it to yourself whatever you
feel called to do put it out there
and then in that moment while you're
writing that fear down just really look
at
it and start to identify all the reasons
why it's insane
why you can laugh in what ways can you
laugh at this chaos
so for instance if you're saying i'm
afraid i'm going to lose my job
look at that fear and say okay well i
have no signs of losing my job i
have a lot of security i feel good about
myself
i do a good job at work this is not the
worst time for my company
really start to see all the reasons why
this is an insane idea
and in those moments when you can just
pinpoint the insanity you can start to
laugh
and let yourself laugh at that chaos
just one
positive thought at a time you can laugh
at the crazy thought and this is your
job to reorganize that story
and reframe that script so that you can
start to tell a new story
so in those moments laugh sometimes a
great exercise is to call a friend
and say okay i'm gonna out my ego it's
totally insane can we laugh about it
and your friend can really help you get
there i often get on the phone with a
lot of my friends i'm like can you just
see how
freaking insane that is and together
we laugh and that's a real incredible
way out
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you stressed out
afraid saying that it's hard this is
difficult
i'm afraid
my heart's beating out of my chest
because i'm still thinking i don't want
to go up there and disappoint people
but instead of being fearless it's like
no i'm afraid
and this is the best because everything
i want is on the other side of this fear
and i'm gonna go off and i'm gonna do
the best that i have and every new thing
that comes at me
they kept saying man you're so easy to
work with you're so easy going
yep meanwhile like i'm panicking you're
freaking out inside
and it's not it's not about putting on a
show it's not about showing people that
i'm
i'm afraid it's about me telling myself
that i do difficult things
some people say when you are nervous
tell yourself that you're excited
because it's the same feeling inside you
that when you're about to go on stage or
have a big call or do something that
you're afraid to do
you're nervous tell yourself you're
excited i don't want that
i tell myself i'm nervous and i do
things that make me nervous
i love that i do things that make me
nervous i build my self-esteem and
self-respect and self-pride
from jumping in on the things that make
me nervous
you want to do things that make you
nervous
and so i got on stage and and
did a pretty good job we had a little
miscommunication on the ending
and uh flubbed it a little bit but
i get backstage and brandon burchard's
running back like oh my god you crushed
it
so much energy i love that guy and now
i'm on to the next thing
and there's nothing in my calendar ahead
that is scary difficult hard that makes
me feel
afraid then i'm not growing
and you're not growing too so i've got a
three-step process that i'm going to
walk you through that can help you step
into your fears that i think will help
step number one is understand what is
your big mission what are you trying to
accomplish what is the big mission that
you're on i want to solve the world's
biggest problem i want to spread more
belief
i think the world's biggest problem is
there aren't enough people who believe
in themselves
and their michael jordan level talent
that's what i'm helping every single
dude
every single do every single day for the
rest of my life that is my mission
what is your big mission what is the
thing that you're afraid of doing
what is that giant thing right now me
stepping on stage
at brendan and dean's event makes sense
because i'm trying to spread my mission
what is your big mission number two is
what's the next step that you're afraid
to take
if you want to go off and have a big
impact change a lot of lives you're
gonna have to do things you've never
done before
because the way you're doing it now the
growth that you're on now
is not fast enough you're not going to
hit your target it's not going to happen
it's going to require a bolder more
confident more courageous version of you
and how do you get that by stepping into
the light
by stepping into your nerves by stepping
into your fears
that's how you grow that's how you
emerge stronger
so what's the next step for you your big
mission just came up with it
step number one what's your big mission
great what is the next step
that you must take to move that mission
forward that you are afraid of
and then step number three is commit to
doing it right now
commit to doing it right now you are not
allowed
anymore to think of something that's big
that's exciting
that it that is game-changing for you
that gets you pumped up ready to go
you're not allowed to think of that
and then be afraid and then not do
something you need to stop teaching
yourself that that you come up with
ideas
then you get afraid and then you don't
have momentum
and you play small you need to break
that cycle
so we've just gone through it you came
up with your big mission
you came with what the next step is now
you need to commit to doing it
commit to someone else that you're gonna
do it make a video talking about it send
that email you need to send out
text the person that you need to text
post it to your facebook or instagram
tell people that you're gonna do this
thing commit while you're feeling it
right now
and then you feel your heart beating
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom you're scared you're gonna wake up
tomorrow it's like holy cow what did i
just commit they're doing
you're committed to doing the thing that
you're a badass at because you're
chasing down a dream
because you have a big vision because
you don't want to play small for the
rest of your life because you're ready
for this
that's why you committed now let's go my
number one favorite question and the
time that
most people use it is if you're really
frustrated or sad or worried or
depressed or you think something
horrible has happened my favorite
question asked myself
is what else could this mean and i make
myself come up at least three different
meanings because what happens is
beliefs become self-fulfilling see once
you believe something you don't see
anything else i've done this with your
audience before i said you look around
the room and find brown everybody looks
around
and i say now with your eyes closed tell
me you saw that was red and nobody sees
much red i said hope you guys look for
red may find more red why do you find
more red because you get what you look
for
your beliefs condition you to find and
then i say
how many saw i said you even saw things
that weren't there how many saw beige
stuff called it brown just to feel
successful they all laugh
how many saw burgundy called red they
all laugh and the reason is because
once we're after something we'll even
make the color different to feel
successful if you think somebody's mean
you'll find meanness in them if it's not
there
if you think somebody's your dear friend
and they do something terrible you'll
say oh they're having a bad day
so our beliefs control us so
unquestioned beliefs
that produce stress those are the ones
you've got to question
and there's a there's a great lady out
she wrote a book called the work her
name was byron katie and she's a dear
friend of mine and she has this four
question format that i'd recommend
anybody looking at
to question your beliefs because all our
pain comes from believing something that
makes us stress rather than saying hey
there's lots of options
in our country today we see people on
two sides of things we're all brothers
and sisters we all
take any issue guns right people make
the other side evil on both sides
everybody wants our children protected
everyone wants our our you know homes
and our churches and our schools to be
safe
let's stop beating each other up and
doing that that's the only way we'll
make progress is find what we do agree
on we might have different ideas of how
to do that
but that doesn't make the other person
evil once you start believing that the
person's evil all you're really doing is
feeding your own significance your own
ego
i'm right you're wrong and that'll never
solve a thing do you want to be right
you want to be in love that's why i tell
intimate relationships
right you know it's the same thing in
life how do you recognize and overcome
fear well you you pay attention uh you
become
mindful uh you sit and
um take some deep breaths and ask
yourself some really good questions
what fears are holding me back like like
just get real
get real with yourself don't be afraid
be afraid of the truth um if you
understand the truth and then you have
some
knowledge and skills to work through uh
you can change that
so the um take six com the circuits is
the first inner size
i'm gonna give you a slight variation of
take six com the circuits as you do the
next inner size
and it's called ayah awareness intention
and action so
in this particular inner size you take
six rhythmic deep breaths
to calm the circuits but here's a slight
variation this is like a little bit more
advanced right
so what you do is as you breathe in you
say in the back of your mind
i breathe in calmness
i breathe out fear so it goes like this
so as you are breathing in calmness
feel yourself getting calm from a level
10
fearful to eight to six to four
to two to just letting go of the
fear and as you breathe in calmness
and you breathe out fear i want you to
visualize
fear leaving your body
just release it remember it's a
neurochemistry that you're feeling so
what you do
is you give your brain the instruction
of what you want so i breathe in
calmness
i breathe out fear or i breathe in
calmness i breathe out stress or i
breathe in
calmness i breathe out anxiety just
a few seconds of that is the first part
of
the inner size but then what you do is
then you say
you know right after you do that you now
become aware and have a piece of paper
next to you
and in the awareness state what you want
to do is become aware
awareness of thoughts feelings
emotions sensations and
behaviors thoughts feelings emotions
sensations and behaviors
so the first part is you become aware
no shame no blame no guilt
no judgment no justification just pure
awareness
then you ask yourself in this calm
relaxed
state where you're able to respond you
ask yourself
what's my intention right now is my
intention to be fearful
no is my intention to be courageous
yes is my intention to overcome my fear
yes great so you have the awareness you
set
one intention not five one one
intention and then the last
a is action
what is one action i could take what
action
towards achieving whatever goal i have
so maybe
one action is i'm gonna write one uh
line of my book
one action is i'm gonna just make one
phone call
one action is gonna ask for help one
action to move you away
from what you don't want why don't they
teach us
before interior empires why don't they
teach us
you you said something very powerful why
don't they teach us how to work through
wounds you don't get invited to
a birthday party in fifth grade there is
a wound there you lose a love when
you're 16.
there is a wound there you start a
business when you're 22
there is trauma there and i think that
is in many ways the missing link in
leadership and personal mastery
and that's really you know i'm
passionate about the 5 a.m club
because i get into that in in the book
and i worked four years on the book but
it's really 22 years of my
my learnings and teaching in the book
and that is a missing link because
everyone's talking about psychology and
people are talking about habits and i'll
answer your question of course
but what about dealing with trauma you
know carl jung said we all have this
shadow side i mean
we all have this well of repressed pain
and anyone who's listening who goes well
that's not me
it's subconscious so a lot unless you've
done the work you don't even know about
it
but it's that pain and self-loathing and
self-hatred
in the 5m club i say you know we have a
magic inside of us the saints call it
the light or god or
nature or luminosity and what happens is
when you do
the work to release your toxic beliefs
and move through your pain and how do
you do it you just feel it
and as you feel through all the toxicity
and the hurt and the wounding and the
disappointment that's called a human
journey
what is left as you release it
you access your light you access your
primal genius
you access creativity you're productive
because you don't have all this
emotional baggage you're carrying
through the day
you've you know i believe that
the real artist the real key to success
is joy and inner peace like that's why
a lot of the billionaires they have all
the things and they're not happy
you our nature is joy
peace bliss love
and when you release that trauma
it just shows up because that's who we
truly are
the beautiful thing about monk life is
half the day is self
and half the day is service that's how
you're taught to live
okay so the morning hours are for you to
fill yourself it's almost like
putting on mental emotional and physical
armor
like that's what a morning routine is
our days are tiring
our days are busy our days are draining
well guess what if you didn't put your
armor on in the morning and you're going
out to battle
how many knives are gonna cut you how
many swords are going to pierce you
how many wounds are you going to come
home with how many of you come back home
feeling wounded i come back home feeling
wounded sometimes
but guess what if you put your armor on
in the morning
a warrior would never go out onto a
battlefield
and life can be a battlefield work can
be full of conflict sometimes
your relationships can be damaging
sometimes your friendships can be toxic
sometimes so
we are warriors in one sense and so
without wearing that so for me a morning
routine
is putting on emotional armor
which is meant to protect you for the
rest of the day
and that way even if you do get pierced
or you do get popped or you do get cut
you're protected and i know that when my
morning routine is at its best i feel
protected
whereas when my morning routine is
weakened i feel weak
and so for me the morning routine as i
get strategic about it
there's two principles you have to know
location
has energy and time has memory
if you do something in the same place
every day
that place now holds that energy
and this is huge like it's just so big
and i'm grateful for that reaction
because
people don't realize how how powerful
this is like when i meditated in temples
that were 5 000 years old in south india
it was easier to meditate
because people have been meditating
there for thousands of years
and so when you find a space in your
home and even if you've got like i lived
in a 500 square foot apartment in new
york
four years ago and i just had a tiny
corner
which i dedicated to my sacred practices
so if you you don't have to have a big
home to do this you don't have to be
wealthy to do this
you can find just a corner in your home
that you dedicate your meditation space
or your reflection space
so first thing location has energy
second thing
time has memory and this is something
that people underestimate when you do
something at the same time
every day you remember it
and time remembers it that's why we
struggle
to work out at different times every day
it's why we struggle like why do we feel
hungry
at the same time every day generally we
feel hungry at the same time most people
if you've got a regulated diet
you will feel hungry you will feel tired
at the same time every day
you will look towards that coke can or
that sugar or that chocolate bar
at the same time every day and so when
you're meditating at the same time if
you're exercising at the same time so
what i recommend to people
wow is your morning routine needs four
aspects and it's simple and i call it
time
it's about making time in the day okay
so time stands for t-i-m-e
t stands for thankfulness there needs to
be
even if it's five minutes five minutes
of thankfulness of gratitude every
single morning
and that has to be gratitude that's
specific it can't be gratitude that's
generic
so generic gratitude is something that
anyone could be grateful for
oh i'm grateful for the sky i'm grateful
for air i'm grateful for water
that's cool but it's generic gratitude
specific gratitude
is i'm grateful for the fact that i have
someone calling me this morning
i'm grateful for the fact that i can
still call my parents i'm grateful for
the fact that
i have this person in my business who is
having such an impact i'm grateful
you know it's specificity yeah so
thankfulness second one is insight
i think this is one thing that a lot of
people are missing which i recommend
people listening to you it's like
podcasts books and and make it easier
for yourself
if you get this book leave it open
on your bedside table leave it open on
your kitchen table
leave it open on your dining table i
guarantee you you will read more
and what you read will speak to you and
i think people underestimate that that
literally like when you have it open
and you just flick to a chapter randomly
and you pick up one line
it will impact you and it'll speak to
you so insight you need insight every
day
m is meditation and i believe meditation
is different for different people as
monks we did walking meditations
we did beach meditations we did
visualizations we did breath work
find your meditation practice i give a
ton in the book and fourth
obviously exercise which you can speak
to even more than i can
i exercise to keep fit you look amazing
too though but it's an
exercise everyone needs to find five
minutes a day
15 minutes a day of exercise if human
beings were able to create more
contained challenges for themselves to
overcome their inner
insecurities that's the greatest game
you can play like i used to play a lot
of physical sports but this is the
greatest
inner sport that you can play is writing
a list of your biggest fears
and then giving yourself parameters and
a
a time frame so i did this with girls
and i was like oh it worked i feel
confident i can say hi to people
without being afraid then when i was 23
i did it with public speaking i could
not stand up in front of three people
and say anything without sweating
without trembling
it was that crippling and i know public
speaking is a big fear for a lot of
people
and i met someone who was a professional
public speaker and i said tell me what i
need to do to overcome this fear
he said you need to join toastmasters
you need to go every single
week until you're not afraid so i gave
myself a year i said i'm going to do
this every single week
i would film my speeches it was horrible
but i every week i would get better and
at the end of the year i remember being
able to speak in front of this group of
15 20 people in the club
and speak without notes you know
remember my speech give it with poise
give it with everything i needed to do
and i was like wow i'm not afraid
anymore
and i've done that with salsa dancing
you know for salsa dancing i spent
90 days all in on salsa and saying i was
terrified that i could not dance
but i did the same challenge for myself
and i constantly do that you know
i did this with opening up about sexual
abuse i was like i'm terrified for 25
years
no one's knows this except for me and i
never thought i would tell anyone
but i knew i was cheating myself by not
at least
processing the healing because it was
something inside that was holding me
back
and every year i'm luckily i'm faced
with challenges every year
that forced me to address my fears it
forced me to level up to own my mistakes
to
take accountability and responsibility
and improve and i think that's
a beautiful thing of life is like i
never want to be not afraid of something
so just because the pieces fail it
doesn't mean you fail
they're two different things what it
means is maybe
you're lacking some skills to make the
business work
that's it's like let's think about this
you how many doors you're
knocked on so do you knock on
two doors and you get a no and you say
man i can never do sales
i'm not a good salesman forget this man
forget it
oh is it just because you don't make the
sale
no different if you think your business
as a sale
you got your first no you knock on that
first door
you get the first note then what do you
do as a sales person
next door next door and you get a no
again
but then how many doors you knock on do
you get a yes
and then once you get that yes it makes
up all the losses
it doesn't matter how many times no one
cares about my 13 failures
once you made it nobody cares now i do
share because i think that inspires
people
nobody cares did you ever have like uh
like a point like seventh or eighth time
after that business like man maybe
like maybe i should you know go back to
target or like you know what i mean like
of course i would be lying if i say no
yeah right but you just can't
but it was a motivation though it's
because i was lose i lost so much money
in the businesses
in order to pay it back i had to make it
work so i knew i couldn't pay back
if i just work for someone else because
i was
by the time the 13 business failures i
was 150
000 in debt wow 150k
20 years old borrowed from family and
friends and credit card
so how am i going to pay that off making
2 3k a month
forget it so i had to make it work i can
tell you if the 14
one didn't work
[Music]
it doesn't matter because compared to
other
i look at other people i ask myself and
you should ask yourself
am i dumber than everybody else do i
work less hot than everybody else
if they can make it why not you so i ask
myself very honest
i work harder than anybody else i work
and i'll learn and outsmart them
and i do you know i mean i never give up
i keep trying trying trying and if you
just take action and you know i made a
recent post on my instagram
saying if you can't figure out what you
want to do in life don't worry about it
just do what's in front of you right now
right yes and then but with the
with the vision of this is a stepping
stone and always be
on the lookout for a better opportunity
just be active you know because if
you're sitting around
constantly asking people oh you know
what's the next business or if this
business is bad
i'm gonna wait for this guy to come from
korea he may have a better business for
me and you're just standing around doing
nothing you're idling
if you're idling you're not going
nowhere trust me i want to remind you of
something you are one decision away from
changing your life
and you have to accept that your one new
meeting one new relationship one new
contact
one new action one new decision
away from shifting your life from where
it is right now to a totally different
place
so what's the decision you already know
i could go backstage now there's
something you've been hesitating on
there's a contact you need to make isn't
there there's a job you need to quit
there's a relationship you need to
engage in maybe there's a relationship
you need to leave
i don't know what it is but i know
there's a decision that you need to make
to take you to the next level just like
i know that's true for me
because decisions shape our destiny when
they're backed up by some massive ass
action okay but you can't take the
action if you don't decide
everyone say yes people avoid being
desperate think of the fact they come
here tonight and they're down they're
not where they want to be financially
their relationships aren't what they
want
maybe they're in a desperate place and
you might think that's a negative thing
but when you're in a desperate place you
take the best actions
desperation is a great place to be those
you that are achieving
one of the reasons the achievement is
slowed down is you've allowed yourself
to feel less desperate
when you were broke and starting your
business or when you were brand new in
your relationship
and you were desperate to get her to
love you or desperate to get him to love
you
you took massive big action how many of
you are moms in the room raise your hand
you mobs if you woke up tomorrow morning
and your baby wasn't in their bed
would you be desperate right away yes or
no big time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you
you'd immediately make the decision you
take massive action you search the house
you go into the street would you worry
if your makeup was on right
how you looked what people thought about
you you wouldn't would you
have to have the perfect plan to go find
your baby that's missing you wouldn't
need any of that
because you were desperate so when you
remove desperation all this
creeps into your life where you think
you have to have the perfect plan and
look the perfect way
and have the perfect thoughts and be all
zen and perfect
what you need is to be desperate what
you need is to get after it
and i want you to get desperate to make
that decision why because our obsessions
become our possessions
which you obsess about most regularly
you will eventually possess in your life
the challenge for most people sisters
and brothers is that we obsess on the
things we're fearful of
what we don't have what we're worried
about and then we end up possessing
those things over and over again
rather than programming ourselves to
become obsessed
with what we want what our dreams are
what we believe we deserve
when we become obsessed about those
things long term
we end up possessing those things can i
get an amen for that yes
yeah most of us don't replace the
external parts of our lives
because those things happen naturally
without thought the external results of
our life in order to replace ourselves
with the next best version
requires intention requires obsession
requires desperation everyone with me on
that say yes
so it's not unnatural to change
your friends that think you're crazy to
have started your business or come to a
seminar or spend money you don't have
they're the crazy ones it's unnatural to
be the same person
you are right now next year for all of
you in here the 35 year old you should
be gone next year forever and there
should be a brand new better 36 year old
you 20 year olds who should be a better
21 year old next year
you should constantly be replacing
yourself just like your bones do
just like your lungs do just like your
cells do it's natural to be replacing
ourselves
but we're around people who aren't so we
think it's natural not to
do you have any regrets for your life
no absolutely not
i'll tell you
i probably would have said yes
15-20 years ago then what happened
i was watching johnny carson's show the
late show
and johnny carson wasn't there george
carlin the comedian was sitting in for
him
and they're both dead now
vincent price a movie actor
was a guest he's gone too
but vincent price had just shot a pilot
and of course they told the public on
television it's a new series well it
wasn't a new series at all
they were hoping it would turn into a
new series they shot a pilot if they got
good ratings
then they'd shoot a dozen more of them
right and so after they went through the
small talk carlin says to him well tell
me vince
vincent tell me about our new your new
series
and vince says oh i think everybody's
going to love it
he said it's about a train and it's like
a magic train
is you can buy a ticket to go back
in your life i would pay for that any
point you want to start over
and he said when you get there i'm the
conductor on the train i stopped the
train now you off
and he said i think everybody'd like to
go back and start over at some point
don't you think so
i thought yeah i could think of a couple
of things where i could have started
over
and george carlin said no i don't think
so
he said if i went back and changed
anything that had happened in my life
i wouldn't be me and i liked me
i thought god what a perfect answer
no regrets everything that happened was
necessary to make me who i am to premier
prepare me to do what i'm going to do
and you see the crazy part about it
none of us know what we're going to do
we think we know right we got to track
but
things happen so the first thing that
people who are incredibly successful do
is they do what they
hate they are fully prepared to do what
they hate
to get to where they want to be and and
people who fail
they will give up their dream before
they do what they hate to do
people who are very successful they
never
ever ever wait for motivation
they do it because when you do it you
become motivated a great writer won't go
well i just wait till i'm really
motivated to start writing this book no
they get up
at four in the morning they don't want
to and they start to write and then of
course they become motivated so you wake
up in the morning and you go
you're not going to go yay it's 5 a.m
i'm putting on my running shoes and
going for a walk
up laurel canyon of course you're not
going to do that you're going to wake up
and go
go i really hate working out but marissa
said
successful people do what they hate to
get to where they want to be
of course the wonderful thing is that
when you do what you hate first enough
times
it starts to become natural like i've
got to do my taxes i'll do that first
thing
i've got to confront someone
and i'll do it first and so i still to
this day wake up and think
oh i don't really want to do that so i'm
going to do it first because what i do
want
is to belong to that group a very very
successful
people so i know what the membership is
and every time i don't want to do
something i think i don't want to do it
but what i do want is to belong to that
group so i'm doing it first and it's
it's a great way of thinking because
it starts to move you around wanting to
do it for all the right reasons
many many years ago um i met someone who
wanted to be a rock star that was his
ambition actually particularly wanted to
be a drummer
and he was a very young married man with
two children to support
and he was going for a lot of auditions
and of course all the additions
take place during the day and every time
he had a job they wouldn't let him take
time off so he decided
he would have to work nights in order to
audition during the day
and the only job he could get was a job
he hated he was a taxi driver and he
hated it but he did it
but he just wasn't making enough money
so he thought okay
i have to work at mcdonald's i get more
money i can work nights i'm free
to audition and about a month before
he'd applied to work at mcdonald's he'd
been for an audition
to be a drama in a band he didn't even
know who the band was
and the day he was due to start working
mcdonald's which he absolutely hated
even the thought of he got a call to go
you know that band you auditioned for
it's actually simple minds and now
you're the drummer and simple mind so he
never worked in mcdonald's or
drove a cab again for the rest of his
life but when he told people that story
they'd all go
ugh i would never work in mcdonald's oh
my god i'd never degrade myself by
driving a cab around london and i'm like
don't you think you're missing the point
his ability to do what he hated is what
made him a rock star
because he had to have his days free to
rehearse and audition
but if he had your mindset i'd never do
that he would never be
a multi-millionaire rock star it was
because he was fully prepared
to do what he hated to swallow his pride
to keep his vision in mind i want to be
a rock star
i must be free for auditions how can i
do that well i have to work as a cab
driver and in a fast food restaurant
which i hate
but i'm going to do it because it's
going to take me to my goal
and it did but the people who laughed
him and said i wouldn't do that
none of them are rockstar 2008 happened
i had nothing to do with 2008
i had two businesses and i was starting
to buy real estate
and i was not buying the real estate to
cause the problem in this country any of
you remember when lehman collapsed
your business if you were in business
your business probably got hurt
i wasn't doing the mortgage-backed
securities i wasn't doing the no money
down houses
you know i wasn't selling that stuff i
wasn't doing mass development
on the backs of the bank with bad loans
but because i lived in america
and i was doing business at the time i
got greatly affected by that
my first two businesses got cut in half
and my real estate was frozen up
i owed 52 million dollars to a bank that
went upside down
new bank came in they started making
demands on me
i ended up in a lawsuit aren't there a
bunch of lawyers in here
yeah i ended up i ended up in one of
these crazy lawsuits
where the guy was going under he had
done some things wrong
and he decided to pull me down with it
it was a frivolous lawsuit that was
costing me 200 grand a month to fund i
had never been involved in a lawsuit in
my career
so that being said um
i looked at that situation and said hey
what did i do wrong here
like i always look at how am i
responsible
responsible able to respond that is the
definition of
able to respond now in my case i was
being forced to respond
it wasn't a lot of able in it so
uh but the one thing that i walked away
with was
i had a baby on the way i just been
married i just got married
maybe three years before that so the
marriage was very new
we were we were really still in the
honeymoon phases of our marriage
not really understanding
who we were as a team my wife and i new
baby coming along
i lived in los angeles i lived in a
beautiful house up in the hills
uh overlooking all of l.a and i pretty
much
thought my life was great until 2008
happened
now i'm taking a second to get you to to
what i want you to hear
i didn't plan on 2008 i didn't think
about a lehman collapse
i didn't know 40 million people were
going to go upside down in their homes
i did not know it would affect me i
didn't know
one of my industries was the automobile
dealers i was working with automobile
dealers around the united states that
was my primary business
i was making a couple million bucks a
year i didn't know
9 000 car dealers would go out of
business who would plan on any of that
now what's that got to do with today who
in their business plan had coved as part
of your
business plan let us know in the chat
put put it put a no in the chat if you
didn't have a plan for that yeah
yeah i need to see 316. i need to see
one
one guy in here say oh yeah i planned on
mask oh yeah i had
i had myself going out one week buying
400 worth of toilet paper
okay uh oh yeah in 2020
by the way how many of you in 2020
january 1st you're like this is going to
be the best
year of my life oh yeah yeah everybody
gave that up
on march 23rd the entire nation of
america
gave up surrender 2020.
look the news the media by by april was
saying
2020 is over how many of you heard that
i'm throwing 20 20 away
fortune 500 companies 100 companies
carnival cruise lines
general motors ford motor company like
mass
companies were like i'm done i'm tapping
out
this year's over wall street every day
i'm watching
bloomberg right now wall street's like
hey just throw away all the earnings for
2020.
let's reboot for 2021 the entire nation
surrendered
uh your kids aren't going to schools you
didn't plan on that did you
see this is the problem with the concept
i think i saw somewhere in your promo go
big or
go home go big or go home
ain't nothing at home folks they ain't
nothing at your house
you're not gonna make your business work
at home
okay go big or go home or home you need
to scratch that
out and say look i got to go big or i
got to go bigger
because going home cannot be a choice
now and the whole country went home
we've been quarantined you're going to
have 10 million probably 8 to 10
million bankruptcies by the end of this
year the the other shoe has not dropped
yet
the stock market's going crazy the rich
are getting richer
and and i don't include us on this call
as the rich
the rich will get richer okay you why
because they think big
they think big they never waste a crisis
and we are in a crisis and the crisis if
you were in trouble before kovid you are
in more trouble
today and the reason we're in trouble is
because
people in this country are satisfied
complacent
comfortable these are the enemy so if
you can take anything
away from me it's like look you have you
and your wife
you and your husband you and your kids
must give up
ideas of comfort now i don't think that
we're born blank slates
but we are so close to that to worry
about where your limits
are is to miss how much you can improve
so focus on how much you can improve
there's an amazing quote by alexander
solzhenitsyn
the author of the goulet archipelago and
what he said was
the line between good and evil runs
through every human heart
to me it's not about good and evil to me
it's about malleability
that's a statement of how shapeable we
are
now here's the terrifying thing about
how we get
shaped it happens when you're young
you get all these things that come to
you that seem to be
simply true i believed
that the human mind couldn't change i
believed that it was fixed
i believed that my talent and
intelligence were just what they were
it all seemed true it wasn't like i knew
it to be a lie it wasn't even like i
knew that i had a choice to think of it
a different way
and one of my favorite quotes of all
time is from albert einstein
and he said the most important decision
any human being has to make
is whether they live in a friendly or a
hostile universe
decision the most important decision
anyone has to make because neither of
those two states is empirically true
but either will immediately appear true
once you decide to believe
it so once you decide to believe
yo the world is working for me this [ __ ]
is happening for me it's not happening
to me i know this room has heard that
statement
once you believe that you start looking
for the ways in which that was powerful
how was the worst thing that ever
happened to me actually secretly the
best thing that's ever happened to me
and so suddenly i started saying how is
this shame of sitting in bed
how is this the best thing that's ever
happened to me how is
this solieri type awareness of
just how dumb i really am how is that
powerful
and the thing that winds me up when i
say that when i talk about i started
from
not being that bright nobody thought i
was gonna win my own mother thought i
was gonna fail my father-in-law
did not want me to marry his daughter
they think that i'm just being humble
or that even i misidentified myself but
the reality is
that's how shapeable a human being is
and i had made decisions
i had chosen to believe things i chose
to value myself
for things i had built myself around my
self-esteem around things
that were not moving me forward
and so i began to change my belief
system i began to change the things that
i
value and think about values
think about how much they shape your
life depending on
where you grow up you could become
one of the members of the tribe on north
sentinel island who killed that
missionary who rolled up on their
beaches they just started hitting that
fool with spears and
arrows and just [ __ ] killed him you
could be that
you could be a warrior of sparta you
could be
a nazi guard depending on the time
and the place you grew up in you could
be a manhattan socialite
you could be a party girl you could be
one of any countless identities that we
see in the world
not because you were born to be that
thing
if we were born to be something then we
would still see some percentage of
spartan warriors being born today
we would see north sentinelese born in
omaha nebraska
but we don't because each of these
places carries with it a value system
a belief system things that are unique
to that group that you grow up in what
your parents tell you about your family
about you what it means to be you
what you learn in schools what you see
in the media all of that stuff is
shaping how you view yourself
and how you view the world but it's
happening insidious insidiously because
it is so invisible people don't realize
that they are choices
now once you reframe all of this these
are things that i'm choosing to believe
and once you realize you can choose to
believe something new
and thusly get a different result
everything changes well there's
something i invented a long time ago
and when you have nothing to draw from
i was able to find strength in every
molecule of this earth
i'm able to be in a room with nothing
with no motivation no inspiration
nothing and find
it so what i did in those situations was
i invented this thing called taking
souls
when everybody's all [ __ ] up and
you're exhausted and you're weak and
you're tired and you're looking around
and everybody looks as bad as you or
even worse
i'm like you know what i want to now
make a statement
it's the perfect time to make a
statement to make a statement to let you
know
where your life ends and mine begins
and so the statement there is i must
drop every bit of strength from their
looks on their faces and how they feel
and how i'm gonna now from my childhood
where i came from how's the bottom of
the barrel i'm now amongst all these
uncommon people i'm now going to now
make you feel
like you're common so i use their
their sadness their weakness their
parts of their life for god this sucks
i'm like all poopy pants they messed up
i use that for my strength and i have
this moment of like
let's say we're in the sand we're
running or whatever
i will do a surge i would do something
everybody's like how the
is he doing this and from that
that look on their face that feeling of
god man this guy must be
something something special it then
surges me further
and further and faster and harder for a
long time
so it's energy is everywhere but the
thing is it's so
loud that that that voice in your head
of pain and suffering and
discomfort and i want to do this is so
loud that you're unable to really calm
it down and say okay
there's something here it's a patient
calm that you have to bring yourself to
say i know i have something here
but that voice is so powerful that just
wants you just to let's leave
right we're done we're done it spazzes
you out and you want to go
versus saying let's take a second hang
on before we spaz the [ __ ] out
hang on and in that moment you can think
clearly
and find that strength out there for you
if you want to conquer your mind
and do the impossible check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there he's this sort of you know
grizzled polar veteran um older than me
but way more experienced than me as well
he's
you know he's crossed more you know
miles in antarctica than any living
explorer pulling a sled